what's interesting with Jessica moad um
and there are certain trends that you
need to pay attention to in America is
uh Laura recart was the lead prosecutor
in the nor el- Malaki case nor El Malaki
was uh targeted uh by her father who ran
her over and ran over her uh boyfriend's
mother together um and uh it was the
first successful prosecution in the
United States of America based on honor
killing and honor violence it's a very
significant case uh this prosecutor who
knew nothing about um Islamic teaching
knew nothing about honor killings was
she
said
that the prosecutor's office became no's
family because no was fighting to get
away from the uh oppressive uh
subjugation and and and teror in her
household by her father and it was a
successful prosecution on our killing uh
Laura reart was enormously disappointed
that it was not a first degree that it
was a second degree murder um and the of
course the utter G uh on her fathers
apart wanting the defense wanting the
death penalty so they could say that you
were they were pursuing the death
penalty for racist reasons so he could
kill nor al- Malaki based on Islamic
teaching but if you were to prosecute
based on that teaching then you're a
racist yes now you look at a Laura
reckart who said while she was
investigating this case she was shocked
at the fear in the
community that women were afraid to
talk that they never put no's best
friend on the stand because they knew
that her life wouldn't be worth a plug
nickel and after they successfully
prosecuted the no al-maliki case they
get every day emails from women in
trouble that don't know what to do
Muslim women so let's look at Aura
reckart and support her and you look at
a bill contaldo who's a
coward who knew immediately that Jessica
moad was an honor killing who was on
record of course if you go to the
Detroit Free Press that article where he
went on and said this was an honor
killing that the father killed her
because she was too westernized that
that article scrubbed it's gone it's not
only scrubbed it's scrubbed from the way
back machine too the internet archives
uh so when you look at this this room
and I will tell you that I'm overwhelmed
and thrilled by this room because you'll
notice there are no politicians here you
know the mayor uh Conor local officials
were all at the were all at the backlash
of phobia that we at the pro honor
killing um uh rally earlier today
but they're on the wrong side they're on
the wrong side of righteousness and you
have to get behind politicians that get
it you have to get behind politicians
that understand it what you're
witnessing here what we have here is
really the the stages the various
stages Mr Corin speaks of Canada speaks
of the UK non speaks of the Middle East
stage one stage two stage three stage
four in the islamization and my next
speaker I I would like to say I have
very very few Heroes if any um uh but my
next speaker is truly uh my hero um I
admire him so deeply and so enormously
uh he is a giant a giant among men um
you know we hear a lot about Sudan and
we hear a lot about D darur and we hear
a lot about George Looney you know out
there you know with Sudan standing
outside the Embassy Sudan never speaking
of root cause never speaking about the
Jihad about the Jihad in Dar for the
millions of victims and I really believe
that if not for Simon D we wouldn't know
what was going on there if not for Simon
D under the Bush Administration I don't
I he'll speak to this and what you he
can accomplish under the Obama
Administration there would have been no
referendum the South voting 99% voting
to secede from the Islamic North after
Decades of Jihadi Wars land
Appropriations cultural Annihilation and
and
enslavement he walked Barefoot through
the Senate to get the attention of
senators he walked from New York the UN
to Washington on the freedom walk there
is no one there is no Warrior greater
than the son of kings and slave former
slave Simon D Simon
thank you very much thank you Pamela
thank you Robert thank you for having us
here and most important let's give
applaud to all these speakers here
they've done a wonderful
job most important I would like to
thanks all of you by being so Pati
enough and being with us here today even
that knowing that in your heart that you
will not walk out in this room today
happy to see or to to hear from the
others you attend a good conference
because you will walk out being afraid
that you attend the conference which is
bashings and lashing
Islam in my
opinions this kind of
conference it is
not an entire
by
religions it is not designed to bash and
Lush
Islam in my opinions as a victims under
the Islamic law the Sharia
law this kind of conference is designed
to bring up things that happens Under
the Umbrella of
Islam and which that
nobody especially here in America have a
decently of gut to tell the truth about
what crime being committed in the name
of
Islams this kind of conference in my
opinions it help people like me the
victims that
happen to be silence because nobody want
to talk about how they are being
victimized because that person is will
be afraid to be called that you are
anti-islam and you are
Islam this kind of
conference it give victims like me the
voice to speaks on behalf of those
Southern Sudanese Christians infidels
that they call
it a chance to F to speak or what they
cannot speak fors or what is happening
in that part of the
world my fellow human beings and my
fellow
Americans this kind of conference is a
wake up
call if you don't allow them to be said
then you still living in a dream without
knowing what is coming to you even that
you know what already have come to you
this kind of
conference it is to expose thing that
being Advocates and
being taughts in the m and I go back to
where I come
from in the part of us in New York when
the blind
shman was teaching in Brooklyn in the M
that telling his fellow followers
Muslims that it is you the one you are
the lucky ones you who made it here in
America to bring down the infidel
you are the ones who will bring down
American and you are the one who will
build the Moses here in the
US he was telling the truth to his
fellow
Muslims but nobody at that time took
that blind Shake an old man that
seriously that he have a mission or he's
on the missions for God's sakes it was
the same blind she
who came
through Sudan come to the United stat
with the Sudanese documents given by the
Islamic government in Kum to come and
bring down the
infidels or to cut the head of the
infidels how I know it because I was
being called an infidels in that
country it was
umman who went
and try to bring
down the World Trade
Center the first
one and he couldn't made it and probably
he
regret that the job would not happen
under his watch so that he will go down
as a
hero this kind of
conference is bringing and waking you up
against because what will come tomorrow
will not Shock you to say that I wish I
would have wake
up yes of
course when an American governments and
persecutors put the blind Shake behind
bar they went and then went to sleep
against they said the job is finished
he's
under behind bar nothing is going to
happen against guess
what my fellow human
being they came and you was watching and
you were sleeping because you are so
naive the World Trade Center was
attack the Pentagon was attack an
American was attacked it
was a
Jihad it was not done by the blind Shake
because the blind Shake is already
behind but it was done by the people who
never even made the blind check
itself that give you the magnitude of
the problem that in hand coming to you
but here
again who won to stand up and say that
no I can I saw it then I'm not going to
go to sleep against being you American
so naive always all you are busy on is
to spend
$2 billion a
week to
protect and tomorrow will be an Islamic
government in
Afghanistan that is what you
doing then why should I be talking about
that let me speak of what happened to my
peoples and what happened to me
personally in Sudan probably you most of
you come to know Sudan about what
happened
in that four
because the crimes in that four happen
on the Muslim
peoples yes we
went
and tell it as it is and giv it the
right name as a genocide of
course I was myself as a victim knowing
that no child should go through what I
went through I was advocating on behalf
of the Muslim
because we have to protect all human
right regardless of being Buddhist or
being a Muslim or being a chrisan or
being a Jewish all of them are human
beings
[Applause]
but what you didn't do as Americans and
what you didn't do as the
West you didn't rise up when the crime
was being committed
by the Muslims on the
Christians this is the devil
standard and I will if you allowed me to
elaborate or to give you a little bit
why I call it dou standard it was the
same
government in Kum the Islamic government
the government that supported Usama bin
L not support him creating Ama
the government brought
Omar OMD here in other words the
government that
behind Bringing Down the World Trade
Centers even that we didn't went after
them in
cartoons I don't know
why if there are the one who brought us
the are one who give the blind shakes to
come to you to attack you and indeed
they manage and we live him
alone what I want to say here it is the
same government that they slaughter
400,000 Muslims in Dar
for and the whole world call it by the
right name as a genocide it is
true killing a human being is a murder
killing three people four people it's a
MRE killing 400,000 is a
massacre and Now My People Southern
Sudanese were so
angry they could not believe the double
standard that happening
especially to us here and to you as an
American are we not human being like
them like any other
persons 3 and half million Southern
Sudanese was slaughtered by the same
government and nobody said
nothing three and three and a half
Millions was Slaughter in the name of
Islam by the war as a Jihad because that
is what is being
designed since those 3 and a half
million happen to be Christians being
Slaughter under umbrella of Islam under
umbrella of so-call jihad
then who have an audacity to go and talk
about it because you don't want to be
accused you are anti-islam
7 million Southern
Sudanese was
forced out of their country and become
refugees the biggest and the larest
refugees since World War
II and some of you probably become to
know the Lost Boys And The Lost Girl of
Sudan these are the peoples a tiny
people I call
them when their parent being parished
their Wonder walking from southern Sudan
all the way to Ethiopia and back to
Kenya and then they end up
here believe it or not if you find one
of them give yourself 5 minutes and let
them tell you what they went through
don't take it from
me these are the peop that when I goes
to southern Sudan tell me that Simon you
speaking on behalf of us because we
cannot have a chance the way you are you
are the lucky victim
and when you are standing up against the
moss in New York being try to be built
on a grand zero you are speaking on
behalf of 13 million Southern sud whom
are saying no to that most not to be
build on the ground zero because of if
we
remember whatman said bring up bring
down America and build the
Moses and you are absolutely right
my fellow human
being I'm not an enti
anything I have Muslims in my family
whom are being
forced to force islamization because
there are 3 million southern Sudan
Christians was forced convert to Islam
by force by the government in
kums the Islamic government Sudan is the
only Islamic country in the entire
Africa and when we talk about the boot
brutality come under the umbrella of
Islam
Sharia nobody know it better than the
people of southern Sudan because we went
through a
lot so for me to be given a chance to
speak of
course some others will say he's so
angry you damn
right some will
say he doesn't know what you talk about
of course you right
against I was
robed with from everything that a child
deserved to be and the child supposed to
learn from Mom and
Dad when I was 9 years old I was
kidnapped by a Muslim
person brought to a northern Sudan and
he went and gave me away to his relative
as a
gift that he came from from southern
Sudan and he brought some
gift of course to most of
you you will be saying no that could not
be but
today you are hearing it from the same
person that happened to be a gift I'm
not ashamed to tell you that because if
I don't tell you he not going to do me
any good it is inside me I better
release it out maybe
that will give me a comfort when
somebody say say to me
that I support you I admire your
work I was given away as a gift in which
that I was
forth as a child 9 years old to do the
work that being always done by the
donkey I was forced even not to be look
at myself as a human being because I was
not being considered as a human
being how how do I know it because the
family himself or
themsel came to me that if I want to be
treated like a human being I have
options and that option is three
one convert to
Islam so that I will
be treated as a human being and I will
be taken to his schools
two pick the Arab name and the wants he
to become their
son of course as a human being to be
treated as a human being or to be look
as a human being I did come close to
take
two Islam and Arab name but the
difficult part was how can I become
their
son knowing what I'm going through every
day knowing that I have to be treated
worse than animals
I have to rely on
leftover I have to be bitten
constantly I know only one word yes and
yes to everything even kids will decide
to for fun come and say Abit which is
beat the slaves and they will gang on me
like playing
footballs and now they want to take all
rob me for my identity of course see I
cannot tell them no all I have to say I
will let you
know
hoping and
assuming that one day somebody may
come and realize that a child should not
go through what I'm going through I rely
on Hope and
patience Pati in God that tomorrow will
be better than
today so people like me when they are
being given a chance to be speak is
especially when it come to the crime
being committed under the Islamic law
under the Sharia law of
course I cannot hesitate to come and
tell the truth because I'm
speaking on
behalf of 13 of 16 million Southern
sudanes who went through a
lot so my fellow human being and my
fellow
Americans living in a denial is not
going to help help us in future living
in a Deni knowing that there is a big
snakes waiting to bite your child is not
going to help you wake up and wake up
America and thank you very much